the vast majority of bats consume fruit
or insects like moths beetles gnats and
crickets
however some bats like this wooly false
vampire bat eat other bats the woolly
pols vampire path can be found from
southern Mexico to Argentina
this particular one lives in Guatemala
its scans and surroundings and discovers
a wrinkled face bat finishing or a
freshing meal of fruit juice this will
be its last meal as it's about to become
a meal itself the woolly one pounces
evoking images of Dracula by engulfing
its prey and it's cape like wings and
biting the head with poor fangs in his
upper jaw to slow
and so begins a bloodthirsty feast that
will last the entire night one that will
sustain the predator for days to come
but just for the record there are more
than 1,100 bat species out there many
gentle vegetarians only a very very few
drink blood much less the blood of their
brethren